Rich Eisen from the NFL Network the Rich
Eisen show on audience Channel 239
DirecTV a few things to dive into
McLovin just gave me a mock draft sir
yeah
now will you click on a mock draft I
don't mean now yeah on October 5th yes
no I will not click on a mock draft on
October but a lot of people do that's
why we have these mock drafts well not
because on a day like today when there's
two American League divisional series
given its ladybugs and the Patriots yeah
but that's later
there's the Dan Patrick show you still
our in two more hours than three hours
of mine and this is just morning stuff
that you can read this your way of
saying you'd like to read it right it's
your show Dan it's your anniversary
happy anniversary by the way what were
you doing ten years ago uh getting a
phone call from you saying you left yes
yeah yeah now did you what was your
reaction I was stunned I was stunned and
I'm it's one of those where I remember
where I was when I got that phone call
from you that you said that you had left
ESPN and I'm like so what is your radio
show gonna be and you're like well I'm
gonna I'm gonna do my own thing and you
were like hey if we have regulars on
would you be up for calling in and
talking the NFL and I'm like Namath name
the time you were very generous because
I think we locked you in on Fridays and
you were there every week for us because
I didn't know what we were doing we
didn't know what we were doing and I was
hoping that you would say to me hey it's
gonna be great or you're like you didn't
the the confidence level in your voice
was not too high oh wow
III was the reason why I was just
stunned that ESPN would be so stupid to
just let you walk or or just not figure
out how to keep you in their employ they
were always more important than any of
the talent there and we were reminded of
that so that like there they wouldn't
allow their ego to go you know what
let's let's go and make sure that this
let's keep him there but it but it's for
anybody look I
when you called you know I was already
gone from yesterday in five years and
Thursday Night Football had been two
years old so I was beginning to really
see the the sprouting of whatever we
were planting at the NFL Network in oh
three and I you know I I never had
doubts in you or anything like that but
the fact that you were gonna start this
show up and now where you are and what
you're doing with it and what you have
done with it and what it is is just it's
awesome I'm like thrilled I'm actually
here on this this day that your guys
celebrating your 10th history but but
also I I wanted your feedback because
you did take a chance you know you left
to go to a fledgling you know network in
the NFL Network we had no idea what was
gonna be and then you just said no you
know it's kind of time to go but if I
remember being a big deal that you said
I'm I'm leaving I'm gonna go to the NFL
Network it was it was an interesting
time I'll never forget it was the NBA
all-star game in staples in Oh for and
you know you know Susie my wife and she
had you know just left Fox Sports and
having covered the Lakers and Shaq and
Kobe so basically staples was her
playground so we were all set up tickets
the whole thing the NBA got you know she
was tight with then the Assistant
Commissioner silver at any rate we're
there and somebody comes up to me and
says hey man watch you everyday and the
NFL Network was on and just 12 million
homes DirecTV was our only home pretty
much for distribution so I'm like wow
you watch the NFL Network and he goes no
what's that I watch SportsCenter every
day I'm like I'm not on SportsCenter
anymore I left you know about five
months ago guy pauses and he goes are
you alright I'm still have people who
think I'm on sports yeah yeah I people I
get on planes and people hum the
SportsCenter TomTom and all that stuff
and I'll get that day SportsCenter do I
do I must tell you though I was just the
other day going to a doctor's
appointment Beverly Hills and I come out
of the elevator and a woman says to me
pause looks at me in the face she goes
are you Dan pad
and I'm like no I'm not that handsome
but thank you for the compliment thank
you for the compliment that actually
truthfully happened two days ago
McLovin gave me bit McLovin loves you
really want to read this much well not
all of them explained there's an LA
angle we're in LA I'm cutting at a
dinner table a lot of USC fans and a lot
of UCLA fans so that was the original
hook of this market where we're trying
to fix the Chargers so I'm thinking if
they got Josh Rosen or Sam Darnell that
I was absolutely just thinking that the
other day when it because that has been
a conversation I heard when you you know
your conversation about this last couple
days that the Chargers are non-existent
here in Los Angeles they are essentially
non-existent and then the fact that they
played three straight home games and all
of them felt like road games and they
lost all of them certainly just sends it
even a more intuitive spin and the only
way that it could poor Phillip Rivers is
if they do get one of the kids that is
so popular here in this town plan on
Saturdays to play for them on Sundays
that that would be a big get for them
like how did the Chargers not see any of
this happening
dollars and cents I think but but do you
think it was just that you know that's
the NFL mentality is hey this will work
anywhere
our fans are gonna fall mean did they do
a focus group or market research I
believe they must have um I mean I'm not
gonna sit here and say that that they
were doing this crossing their fingers
but I cannot imagine anybody wouldn't
just take the temperature here and see
that the most popular NFL team in this
town that used to play are the Raiders
and that was a non-starter for a lot of
people then goes the Rams and then it's
the chart I mean the Chargers played in
Los Angeles one season in the AFL days
there's really no history of that not
not a big fan base left over from the
Knotts if they're even still along not
so much so so it really was not gonna be
helpful if they were bad and they have
not been good at all and this is a big
test for LA NFL this weekend because
you've heard the conversation you've had
it you need three things for the NFL to
be successful you need a winning team
you need a dynamic team and you need a
star
and they've got a three in one Rams team
that is lighting up the NFL and a
bonafide
MVP star in Todd Gurley and it's not
just the way he's playing speaking to
other NFL players and how they view Todd
Gurley they view him like as a Godfather
type stud yang guy that that has the
respect of everyone in this league Josh
Norman who doesn't throw many bouquets
at his opponents tweeted out on the
flight home after the Redskins beat the
Rams here saying I'm watching the film
and Todd Gurley you're a beast so if the
fans don't show up for Pete Carroll's
Seahawks in the Coliseum this weekend
then I think it's another alarm bell to
be set off because the Rams are really
exciting to see I will come back with
Rich Eisen I want to ask him about what
happened with Cam Newton is there what's
what's the next step for Cam Newton with
what he said yesterday and the mock
draft we've got to get the mock draft
and of course is this a must-win
situation for the New England Patriots
all of those items will be answered next
Dan Patrick show I think you may have a
stat of the day for us
I do yeah I'd like to now can I request
which stat of the day music I want you
can okay I I've always got to go Ron
Burgundy okay I get that I - it is here
we go
stat of the day the day that bust out of
the day stat of the day
here comes that what stat of the day
I don't know the exact numbers which is
the worst way to start a snack but
Kareem haunts second half
rushing yard total is more second place
rush yard toast over only you just you
guys second half rush yards
you got crushed by the post there in oh
yeah yeah I'm not I don't have cans on
in the radio business yeah you don't
have your headphone so what should I say
it again now okay
Kareem hunch second half rush yards with
lead the league in and of itself it's
ten more rush yards than Todd Gurley has
as a whole all season Continental Tire
stat of the day oh yeah it's sponsored
yes me getting the post is sponsored
it's the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick
so Continental Tire has all the details
about these great tires alright yes
bowling we have a video for you and I
know Rich's here one of our old friends
of the show who you one who called soft
wanted to check in on your 10th
anniversary of the new version of the
show it's our buddy Ashton Kutcher ah
hey Dan how you doing it's Ashton
Kutcher here I just want to congratulate
you on your 10th anniversary hope all is
well with you I'm still keeping it hard
over here hope you're staying hard as we
men we know a thing or two about being
hard staying hard keeping it hard and
you know I've learned a little something
from you about that because I know you
were having difficulties with that and I
think you gotta figure it out so thank
God for the marvels of magic medicine
Bravo Congrats 10 years big ups that's
Ashton Kutcher who I once called soft
I remember I was helping to me more with
her fantasy team of course and of course
I mean I do that you know it's a great
way to start a story so I'm helping to
me with her fantasy you know I did that
with Katherine Heigl I mean I do that
Nicole Kidman said no I don't need your
help but uh you know so I helped to me
with her fantasy team and she's in the
car with Ashton and she's talking to me
and then I said something about Ashton
being soft and she played it for him and
he was he was like soft like what how is
he calling me soft like he was really
bothered by this and I just it was a
throwaway line I knew I said it he
hasn't let it go yes as you can tell ten
years later that's just go to line for a
lot of your soft laughs ritzy soft
thanks for sure I had a legitimate
injury I think I cracked a rib and
you're making light of it I'm gonna just
I'm not a doctor I'm just gonna say you
bruised something anything worse than
that I don't think you'd be broadcasting
today if it was a cracked rib see
because when I breathe deeply it feels
tired it didn't go to cedars-sinai yes
you should three megive give periodic
updates yeah I've been on the ones yeah
if you want to and you need to leave
witzy bitching and moaning on the one
Patrick show live from cedar sauna some
things never change after 10 years do
they tie alright a couple things to get
to is this a must-win game for the
Patriot absolutely not
no I'm captain alright still play in the
American Football Conference Eastern
Division yeah and the bills do look to
be better and stout but I still need to
see them go into New England even though
they did it last year I do it but I do
need to see them win a football game
with Tom Brady quarterback in there with
the division on the line and make the
Patriots a wild card well how important
is this game because people are looking
at it from one angle and it's the
Patriots angle how important is this for
the Buccaneers to win a home game it is
big like it is big certainly because the
NFC South looks to be and it feels like
it's bigger for Tampa than it is New
England in some I would absolutely agree
with them I guess and then the NFC South
it does seem to be shifting a couple
weeks ago the AFC West was definitely
the toughest division in football
the NFC South appears to be that's the
only division with everybody at 500 or
above so I think it's important for the
Bucks to start fast tonight and figure
out how to put Brady on his behind with
a front 7 and we'll see if grant Bronx
questionable we'll see if he actually
plays Knight I think he will explain to
me what you would do if you were
advising Cam Newton after what he said
yesterday with the reporter from the
apologize you know it was just having
fun and let's go to Detroit I would say
that just say it I mean I and again I
just feel silly even talking about it's
2017 and talking about it other than
just to say that it's stupid and it's
silly obviously I come from the point of
view where my wife worked in the
business for a long time yesterday's NFL
total axis was hosted and produced by
four women on the NFL Network it's it's
it's ridiculous to even just hear that
question from a working member of the
press and see gender and hear gender in
2017 it's beyond ridiculous and then it
opens up the question of this like well
I mean what a women know about playing
it's just so I thought we were done with
this didn't Billie Jean King beat Bobby
Riggs
I mean honestly so just having this
conversation to me sounds silly but he's
made it I guess a national conversation
then of course social media lets anybody
chime in whenever they want on whatever
subject and then immediately say we're
being too harsh within five minutes of
the statement said no so if I was
advising him I basically say just say
sorry I apologize I respect everybody
regardless of gender who does the job
hashtag stick to pouting you know the
mock draft that I am so desperately
anxious to get to here because McLovin
brought this to my attention he printed
out a mock draft for everybody here
everybody gets a mock draft you get him
on traffic you could of the number-one
player in the latest mock draft on CBS
Sports oh gosh it's Josh Rosen would go
to the Browns with the Browns give up on
DeSean Kaiser already and yeah
yes yeah oh yeah oh no the user what the
Browns are gonna do they're gonna do one
of two things they're going to either
screw it up give it up no they're either
going to they're either going to draft
one of the top quarterbacks in college
football
or they will trade the pick for three
number twos
a number three and somebody else's
quarterback that they want to get rid of
salary cap purposes because they are all
about
they're just gonna just combine
everything they've done for the last
three years in one transaction so the
mock draft has Josh Rosen going number
one overall the interesting part is the
second quarterback to be selected is not
Sam Donald is it Josh Allen it's not
Josh out is it Baker Mayfield it's not
Baker Mayfield yeah its Mason Rudolph
Oklahoma State okay now I mean let's
let's just start the fact that we could
pick and choose what we see from Sam's
Arnold in that wazoo game and a Texas
game and say well what happened in the
TCU game I mean I got Sam Rosen's going
in the first round by the way who is
Santa ranger game Sam darn 'old going
31st to the Steelers as Ben's successor
oh there's a there I will say this right
now
okay there is no way Sam Donald drops
the thirty first of all I take I take
this is that what I said I take it okay
I don't think it's a hard tag there's no
way I don't think you're up to the 31st
overall next year McLovin I just want to
point out that I I think this proves our
point about Marcus rich is totally
engaged with if you are gonna suck me
into the morass I will I will play in
whatever Pigpen you set up for me here
alright but I mean I've been fortunate
to be sitting on draft sets for pretty
much since I left ESPN to bring it all
full circle
and I've been to over a dozen combines
and I've heard it all yeah
last year's conversation was there may
not be a number one there may not be a
first round draft pick in this
quarterback group they may they may all
fall out of the first round based on
what we're seeing and what we're hearing
in the tape and the eye and the SKA
doesn't lie and then they were a ton of
them get drafted and then all we hear
after the draft is we may not see a
rookie quarterback start this year not
only we see one drafted in the second
round be the first one that have
actually a start
deshaun Watson is lighting it up right
now and then you know your buddy Ashton
Kutcher will be locked in to Monday
night for Mitchell's your visual is the
second coming all right I got 15 seconds
to ask you this if I said you can have
who's the best quarterback in the state
of Texas right now who would you take
whose future you want dak Prescott or
deshaun Watson
um I'll take two Shawn Watson I just
I've ever since I saw what he did in
that first game against Alabama I
thought to myself this kid is special
then he beat Alabama and I'm like why
would you not want this kid who's got a
heart of gold oh he's a great kid and so
does dad too by the way
so does that - he's got a heart of gold
as well I'm just saying that because I
think it's gonna get the most clicks for
and that's what we want my 10th
anniversary gift to you yeah more clicks
he's Rich Eisen NFL Network host and
host of the Rich Eisen show Thank You
rich the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience